[Music]
okay just got done seeing Nancy Drew and
the hidden snare and the hidden
staircase which is a movie basically
aimed at tween girls if you ask me well
just like the books worth a book thing
so kind of hard for you to review a
movie that it really doesn't intent for
me you know in a certain way because I
don't know between girls and even like
this well I have to say that like it's
been updated obviously because I didn't
read a lot of Nancy Drew books I think I
did read this one like when I was a kid
I was more at Three Investigators person
and the tricks available in that kind of
stuff but I love mysteries now like I
said if I have been a tween girl when
this came out yeah you liked it yeah but
yeah it's like it's there's a lot more
it's a it's a short movie there was a
lot more going on that I thought that
was like three different platform it's
like yeah it was kind of obligated that
they all kind of like intersected yeah
eventually came together but I thought
it was pretty cute like um the girl
that's in it Sophia Willis that's the
same girl that played Beverly in it
chapter one yeah and you know she's cute
she's cute as a button so she's got like
a real good how does she really um she's
supposed to be 16 but she she looks
about that he said okay her friend Helen
looks all up in some shots looks old
enough to drink yeah she looks like
she's about 21 sometimes yeah well they
they do that yeah but I do I do think so
I'm not sure how old she is actually but
drugs very close to the age that she's
supposed to be yeah also linda lavin was
in that she played like it all she was
on Alice yeah he's like I didn't even
know she was so terrible but she was in
this like playing like a saucy old lady
that used to be a burlesque dancer
called easier and stronger but this was
like like I said you know it it's gonna
like um be good for like a certain time
I think like I said probably tween girls
will probably eat this out probably not
so much anyone else the it kind of like
it struck me as like a similar tone to
the for the goosebumps movie that we saw
the Halloween kind of age
is that this wasn't a zany not quite as
fun yeah it wasn't like as Croesus
actually had some said certain certain
times the Tom was serious yeah but it
was weird how that sometimes didn't
really mesh with the common juvenile
humor you know them in between humor
that was in the beginning it was weird -
another thing that was weird about the
movie is that the very the very
beginning kind of had it kind of got
bogged down into some into some scenes
it really didn't have to be there and
some story elements that really didn't
have to be there like you know her aunt
didn't have to be in the movie there was
a boy there was some characters that
didn't need to be there and so the start
of the film seems slow to me and yeah it
seemed like stuff that like the whole
thing about doing the the prank on the
the bully guy you really didn't even
need that that that seemed to kind of
slow it down yeah because it didn't pick
up until she got involved with it with
the haunted house that's kind of where
it picked up and I was thinking like why
did they even have that first ten no
it's like I'm not sure like I said I've
read the book so long ago like when I
was a kid so I don't remember if that
was actually part of the book or not
like that whole set up I know that they
were trying to set up like her character
is like she was kind of like this
righteous personally yeah the underdog
and stuff but I think they could have
done that like in a shorter seek it also
tried I think it tried to make a
political statement in the very
beginning beginning of diversity it's
just be kind of like a pro diversity
statement but you really could interpret
it to be quite the opposite they were
trying to keep the Train
coming into the town because they didn't
want darker elements you know it's all
about that well the the us at no we need
these darker more dangerous elements
coming in from New York because that
will spice that will liven up the town
okay his the town is boring in backwards
and it was just come like wait a minute
hold on what are they talking about is
saying that dark people are dangerous
that was how that's that pretty he
talked about and it's been a I said but
I don't remember like what elements of
it are
yeah or not but I didn't really get that
from it it was just to me it seemed like
the standard and like eighties yeah
manny developing kind of scheme yeah so
I I'm just I'm so suspicious in these
new movies because they insert stuff
like that in all the time you're
supposed to interpret it in a certain
way and if that was an older element
from the other movie it kind of makes
more sense but I was trying to interpret
the message from the modern you know
interpretation of what you're supposed
to think and it kind of threw me for a
loop I'm like wait a minute hold on they
saying they're saying diversity is bad
because her dad was a snake they've got
their dad was supposed to be a good guy
and his whole mission was to prevent the
train from coming through the bad guys
were trying to force the train would be
town they were well and that one of them
was one to kill a guy to get the train
to come into town so the dark danger
their words dark dangerous elements from
New York could destroy the town
basically that's what it is said she
didn't say dark she said dangerous or
edgy or something like I thought she
said dark and dangerous out that's not
still you could sit still scared
to me I don't I don't look for that kind
of stuff in I didn't either it's just it
is said that so when I was like what my
book is I I figured that I figured that
it was probably like a slightly updated
version of this game which is a lot in
the eighties movies and a lot of those
kind of things you know they wanted to
like tear down the nice houses in the
town so that's like I said that's I just
kind of took it with that and just kind
of was it well it did they did stop the
train though that they stopped the
subversive elements from coming into the
town I was probably overthinking
condition to be too overthinking it to
overthink was about well what kind of
virtue were they telling me here yeah
but other than that the movie the movie
was just is not for me it was yeah I
think like young girls yeah maybe I
think maybe she's like she's such a good
actress and she's such a charming of
like character said you know and and I
feel like they they're trying to set it
up because you know it there were forty
bajillion Nancy Drew books that aren't
doing there were but they were up [ __ ]
on there had to be replacing Nancy
Drew's every two or three years that
well yeah because they gave her to be a
Nancy Nancy Drew yeah
riding around on a skateboard that was
another thing that was like kind of like
a lot of 90s nostalgia it precisely at
the beginning cuz she's like she had
because at first I thought it was said
in the 90s because she's had like a
little you know she had a little plaid
shirt on and it was kind of like a
nineties he sounded know they had
shellphone a product but yeah then when
they got it was like modern day but I
was like wow
I'll have that too like I guess not I
guess 19 sauces there should have been
there should have been more of the honor
house stuff should have been a lot more
that should have been a lot longer I
think they probably should have think
they should have yeah it should have
been almost kind of like a haunted house
movie for most yet and done like a
scooby-doo routine where at the end II
find out that it's all fake and then
wrap it up quickly and they didn't wrap
it up quickly enough there was a lot of
stuff there's a lot of other [ __ ] was
going on they were kind of all related
but yeah so me personally I'm gonna give
it a thumbs down but it wasn't for me
maybe between girl my life
[Music]
you
okay we just got done seeing one called
what was this called again we're kind of
cheating cuz it's not a new bout in a
movie this is cruel intention cruel
intent from 1999 yeah on its 20th
anniversary they re running it in
theatres I just hope you guys knew that
or not but actually it's like new to me
because I never saw it yeah I didn't see
it back then either so we thought why
the hell not because otherwise we would
have had to see that terrible Cystic
Fibrosis man yeah this is basically
Dangerous Liaisons it's actually based
on the same French book and everything
the stories I think pretty much the same
and some of the some of the scenes are
were identical pretty much pretty much a
lot of the dialogue yeah I mean
obviously it's updated you know set in
1999 and yeah like upper-class upper
crust New York like prep yeah and
they're like stuck in beautiful palaces
and [ __ ] down in New York and yeah
everybody's young and beautiful in it
and everything they are filthy [ __ ]
rich and yeah - too scandalous - a
scandalous [ __ ] step-siblings you
know stepbrother and a stepsister and
they're just they're [ __ ] demons
basically and they had this bet going
and you know or she wants to destroy
this innocent girl who her boyfriend or
one of her conquest right after and then
he wants to take the virginity of this
girl who doesn't want to give it up to
anybody and so they made this bet you
know if he can't if he can get her then
he can screw the stepsister cuz he's
never screwed her and if he can't get
her then he's got to give up his car
yeah and yeah and that's just the big
year that just the beste to set up this
[ __ ] gets twisted you know and if you
haven't seen Dangerous Liaisons you want
to see that one too
you know I mean there's several versions
of it there's a book called Valmont
there's one called Dangerous Liaisons
my favorite the one with you know Glenn
Close in it yeah um but like I said it's
I've read the play that it was and this
is like an endlessly adaptable story
just it's just such a great story direct
people just these horrible people just
like and like what happens to them and
honestly I have to say that I'm shocked
that I didn't see this back in 1999
because I was all about dangerously yes
killer killer movie it's all-star cast
super fun really cool Agony's good yeah
soundtracks really good and the score
that's behind it cuz it's got a lot of
really good late 90s music in it you
know Gen Xers know exactly exactly what
you know the you know what they're
inferring with these songs when they put
them all oh yeah member that I like what
they did to it too because it seemed
like they leaned into the camp factor
you know and they made it it's very
funny it was like much funnier yes I
mean original dangerously is off was
kind of funny too like in a funny high
school but yeah it's just funny I've
never seen this adaptation because that
seems like a bunch of other adaptations
but I ended up really liking it it was
like really cool like seeing it on the
big screen yes like I didn't really
expect to see it going back in time and
see 1990s computers and 90s phones and
stuff is just kind of cool yeah yeah oh
yeah definitely go see it yeah
okay just got done seeing us which was
it was a horror movie and I thought it's
gonna be kind of like a paranormal
horror turns out it was a science
fiction horror sci-fi but like I said
get out with like that - yeah it's like
a similar it's not the same premise no I
can't spoil it I mean you you can tell
the trailers yeah man just hard not to
spoil this one it has a lot of elements
from old movies from the 80s and the 90s
but it's done really well if you see
what I'm talking about you know it like
it's it's it starts off almost a little
bit like The Shining in a way where
they're going to a place for a vacation
to kind of like going to the Overlook
but there are friends there and it's
just too hard to explain
that's release one hey I almost don't
want to give too much away just because
like I said you know the premise of it
is kind of in the trailer but there's
like a lot more to it like the reason
why this is happening
also I really really liked I mean I you
know I shouldn't be surprised obviously
there was a lot of humor in this because
you know Jordan Peele started out in
comedy you know and there was humor and
other movie as well but this there was a
lot of humor in this and I think it
really like enhanced yeah the horror a
lot because like the family was so
endearing because they you know they
were so funny and they were like that
was part of what I was trying to say
about you know like there's a little bit
of a throwback to this you know because
you know Nightmare on Elm Street had
humor in it and a lot of a lot of good
movies from the 80s and the 90s that
were [ __ ] had humor in it but it wasn't
so much to where it spoiled the horror
aspect yeah like I said well done well
it can actually lay
the two things enhance each other and I
think that really that really was the
case in this movie because like I said
you you just related so much to the
family like at the center of it you know
cuz they were wisecracking and stuff
probably like most people would be
because of this bizarre because the
whole situation is just so so bizarre
yeah such a bizarre from the movies got
is this very strange premise and we
can't really say much about it because
it's stealing its thunder but I do
recommend the movie I think it's you
know it's a good movie I loved it I
thought it was fantastic anyway it
seemed like seem like the theater was
full and I think yeah showing before it
was full and there sure like yeah yeah I
didn't expect a movie to go the way that
it went and it was yes good really like
you know like I said I've seen enough
trailers I knew like kinda what it was
about but it goes off in a lot of
directions
ya don't really expect yeah and you
don't really expect the scope to be very
big
there's the the the movies got a much
bigger scope yeah go see it go see it
yeah
you